buildings and the construction sector
are responsible for over one-third of
the global energy consumption and almost
40 percent of the total direct and
indirect co2 emissions sadly this figure
is increasing i think if i had one thing
that i had to focus on it would probably
be the fight against climate change i'm
trying my best to do this at a
individual level like
eating less meat and being more mindful
of what i buy
but as an architect you have the
opportunity and the skill sets to make a
bigger impact that's the optimistic me
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dami and i am
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc on this channel we talk
about architecture and design and also
some tools and strategies that can help
us have more meaningful and fulfilling
careers in architecture in reality
designing a truly sustainable building
and actually measuring its carbon
footprint is really hard
it's hard to track it's hard to
implement and it's really hard to
coordinate because the energy modeling
is typically done by another consultant
there's a lot of back and forth and it's
rarely a part of the early design
process and
it really requires that everyone on the
team including the client the contractor
the consultants that everyone is
perfectly aligned today
i want to share with you a tool that
tries to make the process a little bit
easier they reached out to me to share
their tool with you guys first of all i
just want to say like i don't have a lot
of energy modeling experience i've
watched my colleagues work on it and
i've worked on a net zero project a very
long time ago i'm a real beginner at
this and the idea of energy modeling
actually sounds really scary to me but
after fiddling around with this tool a
little bit my first impression that it's
really really easy to use and it's
really accessible to everyone energy
modeling it should be a part of every
architect's toolbox in fact ever since
cove tool launched buildings designed
with this tool has helped offset
27.6 million tons of co2 in just four
years first of all i want to start off
by giving you a little bit of background
on what is an energy model and then i'll
be giving you a little
through of the tool and just give you my
first impressions and if you are a
seasoned energy modeler you have some
thoughts and you've experienced other
tools please feel free to share your
thoughts in the comments so we can all
learn
so what is an energy model
an energy model is a series of
calculations generated by your computer
that gives you information on the
anticipated energy consumption of your
building it simulates how much energy
the building is going to consume and
it's used to help designers make smarter
decisions
and it's used to give the owners a sense
of how much the energy bill is going to
cost and it also gives you a glimpse
into the future of your building so that
you can make informed decisions during
the design process
however
a lot of the times that's not how energy
models are actually used most owners and
designers use it kind of as a
verification document to meet energy
performance requirements from the city
or certification programs like lead
because a lot of the times consultants
are kind of involved too late
or someone else is doing the modeling so
there's a lot of back and forth modeling
also takes a long time and it's very
complicated so
the longer your consultant takes to give
you feedback the harder it is to
implement on your project just overall
there's a lot of friction in the process
i think one of the biggest game changers
of cove tool is that it automates a lot
of the painful processes of digging into
the energy standards every jurisdiction
has its own energy standards that you
need to meet for example vancouver is
going to have a different requirement
than somewhere like houston on this tool
you just have to put in your location
the energy code that you have to follow
the building type and geometry
and the platform
pre-populates a lot of the data for you
it also populates the data based on
which climate zone you're in they have a
database of currencies utility rates
carbon emissions weather data energy
code and as they grow they're constantly
updating their database to include more
and more regions worldwide having access
to this data in the early stages of
design as you're designing the building
is going to give you so much control
over the energy targets and operational
costs and just the overall building
performance you can create more accurate
models in significantly less time and
reduce the back and forth between you
and your building scientists or envelope
consultant i really feel like this is a
tool that we should have had five years
ago so if you've seen a tool like this
please let me know and if you're a
developer please make a tool like this
anyways all in all i think this is
something that is very exciting it's
something that should be in every
designer's toolbox and it should be a
part of every designer's design process
we really shouldn't leave it up to the
engineers and we really shouldn't leave
it till in the later stages of the
design to do this modeling because the
best way to do energy modeling is as a
design tool to
help you make informed decisions along
the way energy modeling is gonna be a
part of our future and i think it's very
worthwhile to spend the time to learn
this tool or any other energy modeling
tool and just familiarize yourself with
it
[Music]
so the very first thing that you do when
you come into co tool and you start your
project
is you choose what building type it is
so it can be an office it can be a hotel
it can be
a school for education hospital lab and
all of these will have different energy
requirements
and you also put in your location here
so
let's put in vancouver bc
and so you'll see later that it's gonna
actually place my building in this
location in vancouver
so i know that i'm doing a project in
vancouver and
you know that in vancouver all the
buildings have to be
done to a certain standard and here that
standard is ashrae 2019
so you select that
and maybe if you're in a different
location let's say you're in
um
houston texas let's see
oh look at that they have different
regulations there
it doesn't have the other national
energy code so it'll give you a
selection of energy standards that your
region requires
once you come onto the tool you have two
options you can either use their native
drawing tool which i'll walk you through
in a sec or you can import your geometry
from a modeling software that you
already use revit sketchup rhino
you download a cove tool plugin for that
software
and that plugin is going to help you
export the geometry into the analysis
tool
so
i'm just going to show you how to use
the drawing tool
so it's super straightforward actually
i've already kind of created a building
here but
you want to draw
walls you draw
a wall
and
you can place windows
you can determine the size of the
windows over here
you can add overhangs
you can determine the depth of the
overhang or the fins
and you can create rooms whoops
you can create rooms within
[Music]
the building
[Music]
and once you draw this in you can
determine what type of room this is
going to be like what the function of
this room is going to be once you select
on this room you can determine
uh what function the room is going to be
used for which is going to change your
energy consumption like for example if
you have a washroom that's gonna require
more hvac than
somewhere like an office
and if you have a food prep area you're
gonna need more ventilation so
um yeah you just select that right in
here and you can see that it populates
all of this data like preset data for
you so you don't have to go in and put
in these numbers yourself so once you do
that
you can also create more floors so if
you want to create a third floor
um
this uh you just press this button
and basically
you are on the third floor so let me
just try
drawing a couple of walls here
just to show you so i'm on the
third floor
now i'm on the fourth floor
you see i've drawn in these
and so you go into 3d
you can see those
stacked floors on top of this building
so
let's get rid of
all this
garbage
and then from here you can assign
performance value to
these wall assemblies
so this wall every wall has a insulation
value and r value
and so you can kind of go in and plug
that in there based on what your
assembly is made out of you can do that
same for the
for the glazing you put in the r value
remember i was showing you the overhangs
so
if you look at it in 3d
you can see that
by just sliding this
i can create
multiple overhangs
and i can also change the depth of the
overhang i can also create fins
two fins
and you can change the depth of the fins
here as well
that's basically what the drawing tool
does and once you're done
here
you export the 3d model into your
drawing analysis tool
it takes a couple seconds for it to do
the analysis
and look at that
there is vancouver right there
and so you just
press on this little button here
and you can locate your building
properly
so
once you open the analysis tool you'll
see a bunch of buildings
this is
um
okay yeah perfect this is on robson
square
and so you might have a hard time
finding exactly where you're building is
so you just press on this little pencil
tool right here
and you'll find this little arrow
once you find that little arrow you can
move your project
whichever way you want
and just locate
it properly so let's say it's just
sitting at the corner of the site
you unpress this
voila there it is
um
you can also change the height of these
buildings
let's say you actually took a proper
site survey and you know that okay like
this building is actually a lot taller
so you can go in and change this
building height because that's gonna
affect the shadows on your site right so
you wanna
you can go in and okay you went there
and you measured that it's 25
meters so you just go in and change that
and if you know that okay that's
actually that building's been demolished
and it's much smaller now
you can just go in there and change it
okay
so once you have that
uh unclick the pencil
it gives you a bunch of different
analysis tools so
first of all
it gives you a shadow study of your site
so
click on the shadows and
you can
look at how the buildings around your
site affects
the light that you're getting in your
building it also has a tool for covid
so based on the area of your building it
recommends an occupancy so based on the
layout it's recommending an 89
occupancy rate which is
154 people and it gives you a
recommended number for each
level
it also gives you what kind of views you
can get so you can kind of scroll
through
so sda basically calculates how much
useful daylight your uh your space
receives
so if you're in an office
uh
the productivity increases based on how
much daylight you have so
it has a direct impact on the well-being
of the people working there
and so there is a baseline for that and
it looks like in this building it is far
beneath
the passable number which here seems to
be 50 based on the energy standard that
we put in what we have to do is go in
and
probably change the size of the glazing
or
shift around the building or change the
geometry of the building to make this
passable and asc is basically
how much
unwanted sunlight your space receives
and so the green area is all pass and
then in the red areas are the areas that
you'd want to watch out for and the
radiation gives you a sense of how much
solar radiation your building is getting
and this is a good way for you to
determine where you can put in solar
panels and sun hours is how many hours
of sunlight you're getting on your
building
and when you go into the baseline
section it actually gives you a pretty
thorough breakdown of what your energy
consumption is compared to the baseline
so
this is your energy consumption right
here your eui and the baseline
for 2030 is 301 and the 2030 target is
16. so
if you want to meet the 2030 target then
you'll have to go back into the drawing
and change some parts of the design and
it gives you a good sense of how much
energy your building is going to consume
how much your electricity bill is going
to be and how much your co2 reduction is
and here you can see the breakdown of
your energy usage so what's interesting
here is that you have a
disproportionately high heating load
compared to the cooling load that's
telling you is that you're not taking
advantage of your sunlight you're not
taking advantage of your passive heating
strategies so you could increase the
size of the windows on the southwest
side or you could increase the
insulation of your walls and you can
quickly do that
by changing the value
of
the envelope here and over here at the
bottom it gives you a very general
breakdown of your energy usage so
cooling your cooling load is not
dominating your energy use this is
because your hdd are higher than your
cdas okay so that just means that um
you have more days of the year where you
need to heat the building than when you
need to cool the building
and heating that's
we've seen in this graph that's the
biggest culprit of our energy use so
your heating load is dominating your
energy use that's because your hdd are
higher than your cdd days you can reduce
your heating load by
facade hvac systems or reducing
infiltration
so
yeah you can obviously replace your hvac
system
but probably um what you want to do with
the design is first
by modifying the facade
so like i said before adding more
glazing on the southwest side
or
reducing infiltration
making the envelope more airtight making
the envelope more insulated and your
lighting load and so on and so forth
your lighting load contributes to
21.23 of the total eui yeah and it just
continues to give you advice on how you
can reduce your energy loads on lighting
equipment hot water fans and pumps
and it also
gives you some suggestions on placing
photovoltaic panels
and if you do let's optimize
it'll kind of take the analysis of
what's given and
give you
suggestions on how to optimize the
building
so probably one of the most valuable
features of cove tool is this
optimization tool basically helps you
explore different alternatives to
find the most
beneficial solution in terms of price in
terms of energy usage
in terms of operational costs sometimes
there's more than one way to solve a
problem like we saw in the example
before
you could
lower the heating load of a building by
thickening up the insulation of the
walls or you could
improve the hvac system this tool
basically uses parametric modeling to
explore all of these alternatives and
produces or
suggest these bundles and you can choose
a bundle kind of based on which money
your clients willing to spend up front
and how much energy you would be saving
with this type of investment and what
your client's payback period is expected
to be
and you know so on and so forth
so with the strategy you can kind of see
like okay maybe from uh overall cost and
like energy standpoint it's better for
me to use wall insulation and glass
rather than choosing a more expensive
hvac system so i just kind of breezed
through the fundamentals of the tool
but there's so many more functions that
i didn't really cover in this video if
you're interested in trying out the tool
for yourself you can sign up for a free
trial using the link in the description
and they have really great support teams
that can help you
get started and help you through any
questions that you have so let me know
what you think is energy modeling a part
of your design process
and if so how does this compare to other
tools that you've used also do you have
any great app ideas that could help the
industry let me know in the comments
below so that's the end of the video
hope you guys enjoyed it please give me
a thumbs up if you're not subscribed hit
the subscribe button and i'll see you in
the next video bye
you